all right let's get into the first
mailbag of 2022 we took a week off from
the mailbag last year i'm sorry last
week the the final week of 2021. we took
the week off from the mailbag um
actually we took a week off from the
mailbag the previous week too because i
was traveling so we have the first
mailbag of 2022. that's the point you
can email info davidpakman.com don't
abuse it probably close to 100 people
now send emails so regularly that the
emails are auto filtered into a very
specific folder kept only
for law enforcement purposes in case law
enforcement comes to us and says sir
have you ever heard from this person and
we say yes we have
okay let's get to a variety of different
messages and emails that came in first
one is from someone who goes by the name
gypsy soul
who says who do you think you're
you're not a journalist
just a wannabe youtube star
i i never i never call myself a
journalist that's true
youtube star is more subjective but
we're in the top half of one percent of
youtube make of that what you will
not everyone refusing the vaccine is a
trump support supporter you uneducated
clown
that's true we never said that we
explained that trump supporters are the
most anti-vaxx group but not every trump
supporter is anti-vaxx so far we agree a
lot of pejoratives but we agree you're
spreading misinformation and
conspiracies and lies well that's i
reject that that's a claim made without
evidence if you want to present some
evidence i will examine it
take your vax and booster and shut your
mouth well no i do a show where i
comment
you don't have to listen i'm allowed to
speak see that's the thing about that's
the thing about freedom of speech
you can't tell me to shut my mouth you
can tell me not to listen you can tell
me you're not going to listen and that's
fine
mind your own business
your discrimination
and bullying and pushing and shaming
unvaccinated people and we are tired of
it all right well have a good time i
hope everything goes really really well
for you and uh i'm finding myself
without uh too much else to say to this
individual but that's daily that's daily
guys dozens of messages like that here's
a really weird one i don't know if this
is meant to be hate mail
if this is meant to be
confusing or some kind of commentary but
sean wrote to me and simply said david
sir
i've
hermectin
have you
vermectman tin
vermectementin that's the way it's
spelled
i don't know what the hell shawn is
talking about
but this is a really strange job i have
where that's
part of my job is interpreting messages
like that
and trying to figure out what does it
mean all right now let's get on to more
substantive stuff nigel wrote in and
says hey david
new internal poll out from georgia 14
marjorie taylor green's district shows
marjorie with a strong lead in the
republican primary
this can't bode well for our country
best regards sir yeah you know
we've been saying
one of the big signals we're looking at
in 2022 and this this 2022 is about to
start we've got a few weeks before it
starts
one of the signals we'll be looking at
in terms of the country is does trumpism
do well in november or does trumpism
fail in november
and we're not going to know the answer
for some time but one of the important
things to remember
is that a lot of these weaponized
trumpists marjorie taylor green lauren
bobert or bo bear as uh rokhana called
her
madison cawthorne and others
they are in such heavy republican
districts and heavy trump districts
that their victories don't tell us that
much it's like they're obviously going
to win if they get uh if they run for
re-election and marjorie taylor greene
is one of those people
i expect her to win and honestly
being banned from twitter being kicked
off of her committee assignments all of
this sort of stuff i don't think it
hurts her at all with the people voting
for her in her district so yeah marjorie
taylor green is doing really really well
and i expect her to win that's not what
will tell us
will trumpism prevail long term in the
united states next message is from jade
about california gas prices jade says
hi david i keep hearing you refuting
trump's claims that california gas
prices have reached seven something
while presidents don't control gas
prices and it's not widespread there are
in fact many gas stations along the
california coast
specifically in the big sur
area south of monterey that have gas
prices in that range the reason being
it's just so difficult to get gas to
this area attached is a photo of a
valero and my wife and i stopped at that
my wife and i stopped that in september
when we got married showing gas between
6 59 and 7. just wanted to clear it up
big fan thank you for reading yeah
remember
i never claimed when trump would say
the lie from trump was not that one gas
station might have had gas for 777 that
was the highest number trump picked
maybe 787 he even said
the deception was trump was saying when
i left office gas was 1.87
and now it's 777 in california and
there's like five lies in there one it
wasn't 187 when he left it was more like
220 something
two
that's the national average gas price
and he's comparing it to the highest
possible price that you that maybe
exists
somewhere in california for super
premium
um so you're not even comparing apples
to apples the apples to apples would be
that when trump said
it was 777 in california the national
gas price was like three something
that's the deception and i was just out
in california 659 is the most i saw so
it's not that these things can't exist
anecdotally
it's that um
trump's lying about the entire context
and telling you well it's it used to be
187 now it's 777. it's like it's not
777. that's not the average california
price and that's not the average
national price and it wasn't 187 when
you left and it had nothing to do with
you okay i think we get the point
drew wrote in about testing problems
covet testing problems and says hey
david i like your assessment of the
under testing that will take place but
to add to the reason why why testing
numbers will be short i live in
pittsburgh
next pcr availability is 1 to 22. this
is like a week old email and there are
not rapid tests the testing
infrastructure just isn't there right
now it's insane how bad the testing
infrastructure is in the united states
it's we're two years in even blue states
i just saw
friends in boston
with a picture
where they're like a block and a half
away from a street light
and they said
you have to get to that street light
just to like check in and start the
process to get a pcr test it's hours and
then it can take two to three days to
get your results
should we be testing of course
if you're not super sick
should you go to the er for a test we're
being told no because then we're cl
people are clogging up the ers so people
go elsewhere
but the diagnostic value
diminishes
if you can't get the test for this long
if you're in lines potentially spreading
it to other people in line
and at the end of the day if you don't
know sooner
you know sure everybody should isolate
until their results but it's it's just
this is not plausible
if we are saying this is the way we're
going to stop the spread testing that is
this disastrous is just not going to
stop the spread it's unclear testing
will stop the spread at all when many
people have no no symptoms and have no
reason to go get tested that's a
different issue
but it is insane that two years in we
still don't have appropriate
infrastructure in one of the richest
countries in the world
will wrote in and said how are
monoclonal antibodies more natural than
vaccines david sir have you noticed the
glaring contradiction at the heart of
the rite's grift over monoclonal
antibodies being a safer alternative to
vaccine they promote vaccine hesitancy
on the grounds that they're risky
unnatural and untested
but in what universe is a vaccine which
essentially trains your own immune
system to fight off the virus on its own
less natural
than having lab produced synthetic
antibodies injected into your
bloodstream not to mention we've been
using vaccines a lot longer than we've
been using monoclonal antibodies so the
idea that vaccines are somehow less
tested doesn't make sense either yeah
guys every talking point
i
last time i talked about this people
emailed saying why are you against
monoclonal antibodies i'm not but you
take those when you're sick i'd rather
people not get sick in the first place
or if they get sick
for it to be so mild you wouldn't go and
get monoclonal antibodies they say well
the vaccine's untested and anyway we
have a treatment called monoclonal
antibodies pfizer vaccine is fully
approved monoclonal only eua
well the vaccine is big pharma it's a
cash cow for big pharma
a vaccine regimen is really really cheap
really cheap there's a lot more money to
be made on monoclonal antibodies it's
thousands of dollars per treatment so
the big pharma money grubbing thing
out the window number three side effects
from the vaccine
look at the side effects from the
antibodies hundreds of millions of
people have taken the vaccine whereas a
very very small fraction of that have
taken the antibodies the side effects
can be real and it can also affect your
immune system and its ability to fight
covet in the future
um
all of the natural i'd rather have
natural immunity so i'll get sick and
then get monoclonal antibodies there's
nothing natural about monoclonal
antibodies every argument is is not a
valid argument should we have both yes
but it's better for people not to get
sick and not need monoclonal antibodies
it's such a simple idea and yet we can't
seem to get people to accept it
benjamin wrote in and said this is a
beautiful seinfeld quote it's not a lie
if you believe it
benjamin says hello david sir hope
you're able to recognize i go to umass
amherst i know you're an alum thought
that was worth pointing out of course go
minutemen my question plain and simple
can be summed up from the quote by
george costanza in seinfeld remember
jerry it's not a lie if you believe it
i'm wondering while we're able to truly
tell trump and the rights lies from the
real truth
are they truly lying if they either a
get a piece of information that gives
them the best info to prove their
argument or b
truly believe what they're saying is
true is that lying or just being stupid
i hope the question is worded clearly
enough go minutemen ben yeah um
there's no doubt that
a ton of the people repeating covet
disinformation
don't believe that they are lying
they believe that they're telling the
truth
uh they're misinformed
they are in many cases incompetent
um many of them
want to believe the things that they
believe so they're not also
you know
if i want to believe that the vaccine
doesn't work
and i find people telling me that who i
believe are credible
i will accept it with less rigor and
testing than i might if it's something i
don't want to believe so it can be a
blend of the two i'm going to accept and
believe things that i already am
predisposed to want to believe that's
certainly a part of it
but there is no question that many of
the people falling for this stuff
do believe it they may not even know how
to separate truth from fiction right
they may not really understand what does
it mean to research a topic
but they do believe it and they're not
they're not just spreading this
information on purpose they're spreading
disinformation but they're spreading it
because they believe it's true
um eden eden wrote in about 2024 and
says hey david long time listener and
member for a few years now just
interested to hear your opinion on a
warren buddha judge ticket warren is
progressive with a great track record
boot edge edge is much more corporate
but charismatic love to hear your
thoughts keep up the great work um
warren butterjudge is an interesting
ticket because
if you look at it piece by piece is
elizabeth warren the most progressive no
but is she one of the most progressive
democrats in the senate yes
wealth tax
wealth tax is something it's quite
aggressive and there's a lot of
progressives who love it she's one of
the few people who likes the wealth tax
um
is she the most progressive on every
issue no but she has some an economic
ideas many of her ideas are quite
progressive in the senate in the senate
pete buddha judge
is he the most progressive absolutely
not absolutely not but
is he at least theoretically the type of
charismatic figure he goes on fox news
and just crushes them absolutely crushes
them
energy and youth which is lacking in
much of the democratic party
yeah he fits that bill as well and yet
with a lot of so-called progressives if
you said what about warren butterjudge
they would say oh that is a toxic
corporate
pro-business that's horrible horrible
horrible do i think it's a dream ticket
no
do i think that it actually when you
when you take a motion out of it
and you say what have we had
what were hillary's views
what are trump's views what are the
mainline republican views what are the
mainline democratic views and you say
here's warren's perspective and bootage
and here's the kind of intangibles
she's not very charismatic at all
buddha judge very much so
it's an interesting ticket it is not a
dream ticket it is not the uber
progressive ticket but it is an
interesting ticket and what sort of
pains me a little bit
is that a huge part of the left would
reflexively say absolutely not
because they hate both of those folks as
individuals and that
that saddens me i'm not calling for
warren but a judge it's not super
exciting to me
but
i do think that when we look at these
we really have to take a step back take
a motion out of it and say let's look at
policy let's put it on paper
and see exactly where these people would
fall i think it's an interesting idea by
the way i have no idea what the best
democratic ticket would be in 2024 not
even thinking about that yet not even
thinking about that yet the first
question is is joe biden running for
re-election
um because if he is
nobody's going to challenge him and that
that's for better or worse i've said i
don't love biden's chances in 2024
against trump i don't love biden's
chances in 2024 against someone like ron
desantis but if biden runs for
re-election i don't believe anyone's
seriously going to try to take it away
from him let me know your thoughts we
have a great bonus show for you today
it's actually me on today's friday bonus
show pat is out this week he'll be back
next week we will see you on the bonus
show sign up at joinpackman.com
and get yourself instant access
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below